now as the battle continues in the
Ukrainian city of bakmut an aide to
President Vladimir zielinski has said
they continue to fight in preparation
for a planned Ukrainian spring
counter-offensive for more than seven
months these small industrial city in
eastern Ukraine has been pounded by
Russian forces let's take a closer look
at what is happening on the ground with
former military intelligence officer
Philip Ingram
um so Philip let's talk through what's
going on on the ground there
um we've actually been hearing about
shelling in her son what can you tell us
about that and then let's talk about
back moods as well yeah we've we've just
got some reports in of shelling going
into Harrison which is done in the South
that area that the city that was
captured back by the ukrainians at the
end of last year and according to
Ukrainian officials three people have
died now shelling into the cities close
to the front line is not unusual it's
going on on a daily basis I'm up front
line is enormous you know the front it's
1200 kilometers about the same distances
between here and London and um Barcelona
um and we're all focusing on back Moot
and everything is happening and backward
and why because the Russians of the
capture back moot um want to be able to
get up into some of the um other cities
in the disputed donbass region for
example um sloviansk
um and you they're using that as a
stepping stone to move forward however
it seems as if they haven't been able to
generate the sufficient combat power
that they needed to do to do that They
Carried this spring offensive we've been
looking for so what's happening in back
mode at the minute is the Wagner private
military company have come up to the
back motor River they've captured most
of the east of the city but the
ukrainians have made a clear decision to
stay and fight and along that River
there's a clear area of between 200 and
800 meters which effectively is the
killing ground the Russians have lost
between 20 000 and 30 000 dead I'm just
trying to capture this city and they've
been at it for over seven months now
Ukraine is holding that they're fixing
the Russians in place they're fixing
them from that military perspective to
dragging more military in to destroy
them but they're fixing them from a
psychological perspective and that takes
the Russians attention off what the
ukrainians may be doing somewhere else
right okay gosh that that figure is
striking isn't it 20 to 30 000 losses as
far as the military is concerned let's
look further afield then right the way
through this offensive you and I and
other analysts we've all been talking
about Moldova yes the United States has
mentioned that it believes Russia
there's a picture of Moldova is trying
to destabilize Moldova why is that
what's the significance of it it's
another unprecedented release of U.S
intelligence reports getting into there
to suggest this the Russians originally
wanted to come out of Crimea and go
right and capture the disputed donbass
region and go left and go up to Moldova
and um link up with transnistria now
transnistria is a breakaway part of
Moldova Russian troops are there at the
moment and Moldova is tied up against
the NATO's border now what Russia is
trying to do is deflect from everything
that's going on inside Ukraine by
destabilizing Moldova itself
um and it's a standard tactic and it's a
tactic that used to do two things one
try and distract distract the
International Community
um secondly to distract their own
internal
um audience from the failures that
they're achieving in Ukraine okay
Philippine room thanks very much indeed
for giving us all that information on
what's going on on the ground in Ukraine